hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament we
are in the finals it's magnus carlson
versus yanni pomnishi and uh
after retaliating in game three nipple
bounce back in the match and game four
of the rapid section ended in a draw so
that concludes the rapid section uh
after the
four games of rapid the the score is a
tie and now we go into the blitz section
and the thing is
magnus won the first game of the blitz
section with the black pieces and now
nepo is in a pretty bad position
uh he has the black pieces it's a blitz
game and he needs a win
to force armageddon so let's see what
happens here and it's uh
quite uh quite a game so uh without
further ado let's check it out
knight to f3 by magnus he goes for the
retty opening and
d6 by nepo we have d4 and now
g6 going for sort of a sort of a modern
defense here
we have e4 and bishop to g7 uh some call
it the modern defense i'm called
the robot we have knight to c3 and a6
now bishop to e3 just developing we have
b5
and bishop to d3 uh morphe style
uh we have bishop to b7 uh and now uh
there are
a couple who's that are that are popular
in this position like castling
developing the queen
waiting for the knight to be developed
maybe trade off the dark square bishop
but also a4 also very very playable as
black expanded quite a lot here on the
queen side so nepo goes b4
pushes the knight back and now knight to
f6 puts more pressure on the e4 pawn
but magnus just re-maneuvers the knight
to g3 and everything is now nicely
defended
and here although there are a couple of
moves that have been played in this
position the move nipple plays a5
is a new move so already as of move 9 we
have a completely new game
and now just c3 magnus strengthens his
strong center he just needs to be solid
this game he has the white pieces he
doesn't even have to push for anything
he needs a draw
and he wins the match so knight to a6
nepo develops the knight with castles by
both players
and now h3 just taking away the g4
square
not allowing any ideas like this to get
rid of the dark square bishop
and c5 by nepo we have queen to e2
uh and b captures in c3 with b captures
uh the c captures and d4 c captures and
now knight to b4
with this series of exchanges nepal
creates a very nice outpost for his
knight on b4
and attacks the bishop uh the light
square bishop
which means he he could win the bishop
pair and going all the way back
disconnecting the rooks isn't something
you want to do because it even fails
tactically since you will lose the
exchange here but even if it doesn't
it's still a weird move to play
so instead rook f the c c1 by magnus
and now comes uh rook to c8 of course
both players
have to control the c file it is uh an
open file
so bishop to d2 magnus now with ideas of
maybe going for more trades
and now rook captures in c1 with rook
captures
uh and the queen to a8 28 with the idea
of eliminating one of the defenders of
the e4 square and then just gobbling up
this pawn
as now it's it's attacked three times so
bishop back to b1 magnus of course not
allowing this uh
and now comes the bishop the c6
threatening the a4 pawn
but now bishop captures on b4 this is
how magnus uh
gets rid of all the material on the
queen side a captures and queen c4 with
a double attack
on the bishop and also attacking the b4
pawn so with this captures and captures
magnus has successfully uh simplified
the position now he only has the center
and the king side to worry about
and the nipple will have a much more
difficult time looking for chances to
win this game so bishop back to c6
putting pressure on the pawn
uh and the queen b6 now uh with an
attack
on the bishop here and now uh with the
bishop under attack
uh could you perhaps capture this pawn
it does seem like it's
it's attacked twice the thing is if you
go for bishop captures here
then uh magnus is very happy to trade
everything down just knight captures
knight captures bishop
captures ani for attacking the queen
queen captures and now rook e1
uh this is nicely defended twice the
queen has to move you're going to pick
up the e7 pawn
and you won back your pawn so it's not
not a problem and the magnus very nicely
defends it indirectly
so rook the c8 by nepo and now
bishop to d3 uh with ideas perhaps of
bishop to b5 just to trade everything
down
you're gonna you're gonna force a trade
here then captures captures queen
recaptures on b5
uh all very all very nice ideas for
white so bishop to d7
offering a trade of rooks and now
captures captures not allowing
nipple to create any complications so
queen b2 now
preparing e5 as the queen will also
support this push
and the h5 by nipple making some room
for the king but also
at some point you might be able to
dislodge the knight with h4 and so on
so queen d2 by magnus and the now queen
to a8 again putting pressure uh
on the e4 pawn with e5 uh and now
characters captures the knight is under
attack knight to d5
and now bishop to e4 with a double
attack here
you cannot move the knight as the queen
hangs so bishop to c6 pretty much
forced and now magnus could try could
try a lot of things but he tries this a
very sneaky e6 idea
which looks very nice if you capture the
bishop captures on g6 obviously very
strong
uh but nepo plays f5 and with this move
he he he kind of grabs
more space here in the center of course
you do not want to capture this the
light square bishop is a is a
well noteworthy defender uh but uh
that's exactly what he does he goes for
bishop captures on the five with bishop
captures
uh and now it's kind of a problematic
situation
because the if you allow these captures
then you're also going to lose the pawn
here once the queen recaptures
so magnus goes knight to h4 now
defending the g2 pawn
uh and now also if bishop captures here
just knight captures on g6 so first nepo
defends his g7 pawn with the king
and now comes a move that
[Music]
well is just very interesting and which
also shows that magnus now realizes that
nepo's position is better and that he
might be able to create some serious
chances here as he still
does have the bishop spare so here
magnus goes for knight g captures on f5
and now
he gives up a knight to open up the
king's position and
well even if he will maybe not be
successful in checkmating the black king
he only needs a draw here and if he can
get some sort of a
uh let's say after this is captured
queen g5 now you might
be able to do some checking here maybe
this is possible
it's hard to say nepo needs to defend
properly so here nepal finds queen to a1
check
uh which also now if knight captures the
bishop will be nicely guarded but also
just remaneuvering the queen so king h2
queen e5 with check and now f4 blocking
the queen but now
uh queen captures an e6 and this is a
this is a good pawn to grab however
instead of capturing queen f6 would have
been much more problematic for magnus
because here
after even if you capture with czech
king g8 and now
you have to play something the knight
really doesn't have any squares you have
to capture an f5 and after a queen
captures you can just trade here
or even better capture with the bishop
here and then after
things get traded off captures captures
you get this position where it's a
bishop pair and the pawn
against the knight and three pawns sure
you will have to work for your meal but
most likely black will be able to
prevail here
so uh instead uh after this f4 move uh
we have queen captures an e6 by nipple
but now magnus can play queen captures
on h5
king g8 and the knight captures on f5
and now with the queens still on the
board
it's much more trickier for for nepal to
look for winning chances so bishop back
to f8
and now queen g5 check king of seven and
now queen to h5 check of course magnus
will now
continually uh uh check the the black
king
queen g6 blocking and knight h6 check
uh if you go back we just repeat so uh
we have bishop captures on h6
trading off a pair of bishops and now e6
blocking check we have queen to b7
with check now comes king g8 queen to c8
check and now king to h7 you can't wait
too long you have to continually make
moves uh to get that three second
increment as they are both
extremely low on time and now it's a
queen and
three pawns against the queen bishop and
pawn so queen back to b7 magnus of
course very happy with continuous checks
as he only needs a draw
and queen to f3 now just keeping keeping
an eye on everything we have queen to f6
and the now comes queen e for
check king to g8 and again magnus
repeats to grab some time on the clock
bishop f8 and now just to go back queen
to e4 a nice centralizing move with the
queen
king the g7 and now g3 and now magnus
uh will either wait to see what happens
or he will start pushing those pawns and
will then see what happens so queen b to
check by nipple
and of course queen g2 just blocking
magnus would be very happy with a queen
trade
we have queen to b3 declining uh and now
comes queen to e2 it might sound weird
that magnus would be happy with a queen
trade as he's the one who's down a piece
but
uh if you trade here i mean it's three
connected past pawns uh this pawn can
never cross you can just trade here and
i mean black has no no more winning
chances if this pawn gets exchanged
uh it's at least a draw for white so
here after queen g2 we have queen back
to b3 of course nepo has to decline
and the queen e2 now uh we have bishop
to d6
uh and now h4 uh we have king to f6
and now queen to d2 putting pressure on
the bishop here
queen to d5 now nepo's queen trade does
make sense because if you trade here
then this pawn uh is now a pass pawn so
you don't have to worry
worry about it for example king g2
you're gonna go after the
uh the g pawn king f2 you're gonna go
here
threaten this and if king of three
bishop c5 for example
taking away the squares from the white
king and at some point
white will either have to push upon to
lose this pawn or over extend with the f
pawn and then you're just gonna
go the other way uh so here instead of
all that
we have queen to b2 with check once
again
uh so the king is in check king f7 and
now again
queen to e2 this is one trade magnus
cannot accept queen d4
and now king to h3 we have queen to c5
and now queen e4 again magnus
centralizes and the queen to h5 now
uh so not allowing any any uh uh
you know uh ideas on the seventh rank so
queen to b7 check
uh it's still an idea on the seventh
rank only from the other side
bishop to e7 and now queen to e4 we have
queen to d5 now again offering the same
trade uh magnus of course cannot accept
this
and the queen to h7 check or rather you
could accept it but
this is much much safer so king e8 ended
now h5 and now with this pawn already on
h5
things are becoming very interesting
because as uh you know uh
if this pawn gets to h6 or h7 then a
queen trade would be
very much in favor of white so queen to
h1 check
king to g4 and queen d1 check and now if
nep of course wants he can just continue
checking magnus but if the game ends in
a draw of course
it's magnus who wins the match so queen
d1 check king to h3 and now nipple has
to do something else queen d5
but now it's magnus's turn to check not
here but a rather queen to g6 check king
to d7
and now even h6 and now this pawn is
really becoming a problem
so queen h1 check we have a repetition
here king g4
queen d1 check king h3 nepo repeats
again
uh but not no not again but rather queen
to d4 now
guarding that queening square but just
h7 and now the thread is just queen g8
h8 and that's it
so here bishop to f6 adding another
defender to the
to the h8 square and now queen to f7
check with king to d6 and now
queen to f8 to check king to d5 we have
queen to g8
uh and here queen to a1 uh threatening
against some uh some back rank
issues ideas so queen to f7 and queen to
h1 check but magnus has a square
available for his king king g4
queen d1 check and magnus just repeats
king h3 this is a carlson's favorite
maneuver this game
uh queen f1 check we have king to g4 and
now quinta a2 check
magnus is very happy on the h3 square uh
and here
nepo has to play something else
otherwise it's just a three-fold
repetition and he loses the match so he
plays queen to b2
but now he parts with the e6 pawn and
things are now looking
excellent for white so queen the d7
check
king e4 you don't have the access to d5
square so king e4 you're gonna capture
on e6 with
check king of three and now queen to d5
with
check and now it's three past pawns
against the bishop which is already
more than enough compensation so king e3
getting out of check
queen uh we have king to g4
and now bishop to h8 uh we have queen to
f3
again with check hoping for some silly
moves so you can just uh
trade queens uh but of course king d4
but now
queen d1 with check king to c5 and here
queen to d7
just uh keeping around that king not
allowing any checks uh yeah you could do
some queen to e2 checking moves but
the black ink will just march up the
board so it's not an issue
so here nepal tried queen to f6 but this
is just a terrible blunder in in a
position like this
uh instead of this you you could try
something like king to c4
just uh just uh get you know
allow the game to progress further
without simplifying
or or anything but here with the queen
to c6 move uh now it's completely
winning for magnus and now
feel free to pause the video and find
the quickest way to victory
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
and by quickest i mean the only way to
victory
so uh i do imagine everyone got this one
so congratulations everyone
and in case some of you are uh just here
to enjoy the show
uh here it is queen to f5 with
check and now with that with the queens
traded off it's just a very simple
uh and here uh there's just not much you
can do king d6 was played
queen captures bishop captures and now
king f5 grabbing more
squares for the king king e7 defending
now king g6 with bishop to h8
and here magnus played g4 and it was in
this position on move 92 that
yanni pony resigned the game and the
first match
goes to magnus so nipple will get his
chance tomorrow to equalize and then
maybe force the third match or if not uh
tomorrow then
magnus carlsen will be the winner of the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
here he resigned because there are no
moves for black to play you could
prolong the game a little bit but the
white will just push the pawns and
that's it you're gonna push f5 let's say
king e8 you're gonna push
f6 king f8 you're gonna uh get the king
the other way so you can push this pawn
to g6 g7
let's say king of seven you push the
king back king of fade king e6 and now
that's just it king e8 g8 g7 and that's
it
bishop has to uh be given away and uh
black is getting checkmated
so of course nepo knows this and after
g4 he decided to resign the game
so very very exciting game and it's
really interesting
that uh you know uh it's often like this
one when magnus
not just magnus anyone when you need a
draw all of a sudden you just sacrifice
a knight and things get crazy
and then you either win or lose here
here magnus was
able to win it uh in the end because nip
of course could not uh could not accept
a threefold repetition
so uh that's the already a third game
we're showing from this match so sorry
about a bit more games today hope you
guys don't mind
uh i would like to thank arun kumar aru
mugam
harshid gosh jeff graves don dugan and
david black for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chess 24
legends of chess
cheering up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the world of chess
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day